you were banking on this discount
you didn't have a seg plan b yeah you
didn't have a plan b there literally was
no ban b you didn't have you needed the
discount bro
you're a joke
[Music]
all right
guys we're here yeah mum happy monday
fun day hope you live in lavish as
always um
you already know where to go
quickly pause discovery on over to
patreon.com
forward slash
shits and gigs over there you're gonna
find a wealth
of
extra content funny [ __ ] personal [ __ ]
some laughs some tears whatever
blood sweat and tears have gone into
that patreon yeah mum um
if you've been joining us for the zoom
calls that we've been having every month
over at patreon
they're a lot of fun we can't wait to
see you next time next invites are
headed out um
soon so
look out for those um as always guys if
you're watching on youtube two fingers
of death ring that notification bell so
you know when we're posting our new [ __ ]
2022 is going to be a very very very
very very busy year for us thanks which
means it's going to be a busy year for
you you're gonna need those
notifications on so you know when shit's
just flying out the content is just
gonna be churning yeah conveyor belt
yeah um and obviously we can't sit here
every single time and remind you when
the next thing is gonna drop you're
gonna have to flick the beam flick the
bell
um and get yourself notified while
you're over there little red thing says
subscribe bang that click that clickety
clack help us help you help us help you
um
you already know you should already
while you're listening to this you
should be already in the comments chirps
in a way
chirps in a way that's what you should
be doing you should be hearing me say
this whilst you're papa papa
chirps in a way yeah man this is the
season of love guys we've got a month
until valentine's day fast approaching
fast approaching tinder hinge audem
thing there in the past bro bumble thing
there we've got time for that
comments straight to the house
chirp sitting we need breeding grounds
for the
eventual move we're going to bring some
pink kool-aid all will be wearing white
robes
grassy hills
cult locations okay sng cult is slowly
gathering but we need breeders so
chelsea ting in the comments build some
love bust some nuts and we're gonna move
on from there guys yeah mom um
always as always
would love if you left a nice little
review for us spotify apple podcast give
us a rating currently we're five stars
can't be helped second best podcast
second biggest podcast in the world it
literally can't be helped sorry to all
you other podcasters out there
um
who can't keep up with the levels yeah
it's not it is what it is it's not our
fault
which is not my fault um
that's what i'm going to say at the end
of this year
um
but yeah without any further ado guys
thank you very much for being here this
year we're looking forward to spending
time with you and uh i'm gonna throw you
on over to file ordwaks he's going to
hit you with some fun facts yeah man
let's go um this one is about your babes
maya jammer
[Applause]
yeah it's going to be it's going to be
sad news
why would it be sad news oh because she
just got engaged oh yeah yeah she didn't
get it but that's not the fact okay i
know she got engaged yeah that's the sad
news
that's a sad news for a lot of people
with it yeah she engaged some waste man
ben simmons waste man bro where did he
play is it philly yeah yeah somebody's
bane of philadelphia
[ __ ] ass ben simmons
oh
playoffs but you're securing my goal
my goal maya engagement thing hey
what could she say what can you say
isn't it the nigga's like 6 ten there's
nothing i can do there's nothing you can
say bro he his wallet will knock me out
his wallet will not hundred percent and
he's
tall tall
he has two athlete he's total
he's literally lighter skinned than i am
dick he's american
yeah fan was literally nothing no you
can do there's nothing you can do he's
got way more money than maya jammer i
don't have half the money my jam has i
don't have a quarter of the money my
damn house
i don't stand a [ __ ] chance yeah man
there's ways it is what it is but yeah
what's she saying anyway
so about 16 maya jammer decided to leave
home and move to london to pursue a
career in media and tv
initially she wanted to be an actor so
she slowly transitioned into presenting
into a presenting role in which saw
major opportunities
she worked three part-time jobs in order
to afford her rent one of them was a was
a runner-making tea and a music content
creation company where she began
networking and landed her first role
presenting as a teenager
since then she transitioned into
becoming a primetime tv star having
appeared on presented over 40 shows in
in industries ranging from sports music
and entertainment she's achieved a
millionaire status at 24
just six years into her career and has
now launched her own face mask company
that midgie thing on media where it's
called and which will generate another
source of income adding to a million
status
uh so in 2020 she founded the face mask
and it sold out within the first 24
hours
fam
it's difficult to communicate it to
people who aren't from england
but maya jamie is
a staple yeah she's in this country yeah
yeah she's the face of tv or like
presenting or whatever when it comes to
she literally is yeah she's been doing
this
being no one doesn't know who maya
jammer is everyone knows who maya jammer
is yeah and she's banging dirt banging
she's banging bro wait where's she from
what country she's from again she's
somalia somalian you know i thought
she's mixed race but she's like her
black is somalia so um
again that's a that's that's no easy
task
she's done it well she's done it well
bro um yeah [ __ ] hell um she's
absolutely
killing it actually you know what
both millionaires and they're both caked
as [ __ ] caked as [ __ ]
as [ __ ] bro yeah yeah man it's it's it's
good to see yeah my jammer is
so famous
chunks is so close it's so funny
they've been putting in that sense work
bro oh years years and years and years i
was actually listening to an interview
with my german one time she was talking
about like her i didn't know she moved
solo ting to london when she was 16 i
didn't know that either
but i did she did talk about when she
moved over and she was doing before she
got like representation she was doing
presenting jobs for anyone that would
ever think we had this company yeah we
might have off camera yeah
um anyone that would have a phone
practically nothing yeah yeah
practically nothing um and then she said
once she got like a manager of stuff
they put a stop to all of that chat
said you're getting mugged off yeah i
know i know how you're [ __ ] among
what she did i think when she did the
world cup
thing in brazil i think of 20 what you
mean now 22. when was the world at 18. i
think maybe it was
world cup 16 2016 she did i think that
was in brazil she did the thing with
poet she was she was over there with
poker
yeah that was one of the first her first
big deals that she did [ __ ] one of the
sounds big deals usually i can't
remember what year it was but it was
last not last world cup maybe two world
cup score three world cups ago she was
there she was about presenting yeah it
was like copper
i can't remember what it's called but
actually that's fair play is another one
who fascinates me as well in what sense
he is how do i explain it
he's the most
like
mainstream yet not mainstream guy okay
so if you if you take a look at like uh
my jammer and trunks for example mm-hmm
both of them obviously been grafting
grafton grafton grafton building
relationships doing all these things and
then
they've just hopped over the fence my
gemma obviously because she's a
presenter she has to be mainstream
so she's a little bit different but
chunks for example youtube youtube
youtube all these things on youtube and
then
he's just recently trickled over into
more mainstream stuff
he's out there doing like soccer raid i
think he's got to deal with um
[Music]
my why doesn't my brain work um
what's the [ __ ] football show
football show um
soccer am soccer i am i'm pretty sure
he's got or is it match of the day it's
okay it's definitely not much of the day
he's sure
i watch machine learning
today
i've not heard a whisper of him and
slash magic i've not seen chunks xmotv
anywhere it's not match of the day it's
okay
i'm pretty sure he's gonna deal with
soccer yeah
and he's doing more mainstream stuff he
did the mobos
um he's doing bear [ __ ]
and um
yeah he's he's busy and um
poet
has been
known and relevant in certain circles
for like a decade plus
for a very long time poet's been polo
used to use the rap he used to make
didn't even know that yeah poker used to
do grime he used to rap he's got a track
with i can't remember who the other guy
is but it was one specific song
that i remember you seeing on chinese
poet and poet and scribbs oh okay yeah
poetry for the life you don't remember
the song's called i'ma find it now
actually
nostalgia
i think it was scribbs
hold on
poke it
and it's just it is actually poking
scripts wow what a memory
never it's called never going to blow 13
years ago
that's the only
track i know of poet and i remember
hearing that in china you're thinking
this is actually a banker this is
actually a vanguard and this is way
before obviously he's um
presenting and youtube
podcasts and all of that [ __ ] and he's
been busy with all of these things for a
long time and he has from what i can
gather like even shows that he's not
necessarily the face of a lot of them he
has involvement with and then he like
you said like like a world cup thing
here and there he does like drips and
drabs of like these really big things
but then it's like
it seems like he refuses
to
go main like i feel like he refuses to
work for someone which is a good thing
um but like
you can tell like maybe maybe he doesn't
have as many opportunities as it would
seem but for someone as like well known
and has like such a foundation you feel
like it could potentially be easy for
him to just like
scooch over and just pattern himself a
little something yeah and be cake
obviously he makes money but like um
you can tell by the way he talks like on
the things i've seen him on and stuff
like that that he seems like he would
never work for anyone ever i
clearly because i don't watch any of his
like stuff or whatever so i don't have
as much insight as you do but
because poet's been out or
around a lot longer than i.e chunks
philly maya all these like
now he was one of the
foundation people to get to for these
people to get to where they are today
well he actually
been about he was
putting people on
he had a big following on youtube before
youtube was paying [ __ ]
he had a big follow on youtube before
youtube was paying people and then he
like you said he would bring these lot
on
and let them
them these harry panera these chunks
these feelings man now well he's care
not ksi but like his crew but like all
these look like poet was the fir one of
the first guys to be doing this
mainstream entertainment funny kind of
guy blah blah blah on youtube whatever
yeah he was one of the first people one
of the first people
and yes props to hear me still go
proper random poet appreciation day
thank you thank you poppy he's still
going strong he's still got his um
podcast he's still doing his shows he's
still doing what he's doing still
featuring still relevant
busy he's busy he's you can't knock it
he's still [ __ ] busy someone needs to
just give him he's still a young mill
i don't know if he needs it or not i
don't know if he needs to give the guy a
meal for his flowers he's put hard work
into this industry there's a it's just
he seems like one of those guys that
okay it's gonna be
like um there's a lot of like
there's like how to explain it so for
example there's like comedians that have
died in the last few years has it
actually died actually died okay
and like they could be american or
whatever but it's only other comedians
who are relevant and big
that give those comedians their flowers
and you're like i've never heard of this
guy yeah yeah yeah i've never [ __ ]
heard of this guy but the big the dave
chappelle's the kevin hart they're like
this guy's the reason i am i'm a
comedian and he never got the flowers he
decided richard pryor for example
everyone knows of rich bro but i never
listened to rick when i was a kid fan i
got lucky i was friends with a guy
called richard coincidentally called
richard yeah um who was random a white
guy who was randomly really in and i've
always been into stand-up comedy and
stuff he's really into richard pryor and
he had these richard pryor dvds
from back a day obviously like
the their dvds but the set is from like
the 80s
um
and he would lend them to me and they
were [ __ ] hilarious
hilarious richard is one of the funniest
comedians he's one of the only comedians
from that era
that like you can listen to his [ __ ]
today and it's still [ __ ] funny okay
[ __ ] funny okay um
and then um
yeah richard pryor is like yeah but he's
again like for people like who aren't
like me who like have a random deep dive
knowledge of richard pryor from when i
was a kid yes he's one of those people
that you just you hear his name and you
know he's like a big deal but it's only
other relevant comedians that can be
like this guy
is the reason
comedy is what comedy is yeah yeah yeah
he was the foundation he was the
foundation like he was like the first
humongous black comedian
who was just like
his comedy was outrageous yeah and he
had like such a mix of audience like he
didn't just have a black audience like
he had a huge like
global sensational audience like he was
just so loved for everyone he was like
that first pivotal like one of the
greatest comedians who ever lived and
like set the path for all the people
that people love today and i feel like
one day
whether he's alive or dead he's too
young for it to be when he's dead but
poet there will be a poet appreciation
day yeah one day yeah where there's
gonna be like you know the random like
lifetime awards yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like a youtube
lifetime yeah yeah yeah and then it's
gonna be like no one understands who
it's gonna be and it's randomly gonna be
poet
and then people are loads of people like
who [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah but then they
from you're going to get your chunks is
your myers your happy neros you're going
to get all these people yeah your
phillies like stand up all the people
that you know are going to stand up and
be like this [ __ ] guy
invited me onto the [ __ ] boiler room
randomly
when i wasn't anyone
because he saw that i was i had
potential and he gave me all these
opportunities and he sat down with me
for hours and gave me all this knowledge
and told me what not to do and told me
what to do yeah and like allowed gave me
the pathway to just bang
bang i was gone
and then he just kept grinding kept
grinding he's not changed his approach
his style his look he's and he's still
had these same twists since 13 14 years
ago since channel you day's brother
man i was in secondary school man walks
around with head scarves
bro he's doing him with a head scarf and
a bucket cap
he don't give a [ __ ] he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's a guy he's a room in him yeah
he's a real guy
you have to give me his flowers i'll be
chuffed to meet him well you have it's
the same way when
a few episodes just months ago when
we're talking about rap like chip and
all these like
you have to give chippy's flowers
there'll be a rant there'll be another
random lifetime award for chip and
everyone who the flying [ __ ] is that
chip's been about damn school it's in
school days bro chip did he chip
16 15 16 years ago this [ __ ] started
rapping yeah he still looks the same bro
like you gotta give these people their
flowers man yeah a lot of people won't
know
but a lot of people won't know who they
are like haven't been privileged to be
in that era of when they were coming up
or whatever but spam oh my days yeah bro
them old days then bb case
then boy better knows
[Laughter]
yeah
those are those were the days those were
the days but yeah those are so many
people that will never ever ever
get the appreciation
that they deserve they deserve yeah and
um some people will get appreciated into
them but some people
yeah it takes one of those random awards
for people to realize like your
relevance
and just like
some people just not even like an award
or anything some people literally just
need a stand-up ovation thank you thank
you so much for what you've done for us
thank you for paving the way thank you
for paying and it's i feel like if
technology at its height now was what it
was
if technology as it is now was what it
was 15 years ago poe would be a
billionaire poll be gone clear you know
media social media the way the internet
is everything has obviously helped the
newer age today oh 150 years ago nothing
was there bro 100 nothing was there for
us there's fam there's literally guys
literally like that like guys like poet
who were just born
five years too early
and it's [ __ ] suck it's unfair on
them but they've still
managed they've still managed to stay
relevant
up into the point where it pays
dividends yeah
where a lot of people would have quit
because it's a useless endeavor but then
when it becomes not a useless endeavor
that's when people want to hop back on
people want to hop back on and stuff
like that and it's just like you just
have to stick
with it you just have to like you said
like if he was born five ten years later
bro and he just took the exact same path
again he'd be him yeah i don't know if
he's not i don't know if he's a
millionaire he's not but he'll be he'll
be clear he'll be gone clear clearly
he'll be gone clear bro clear and he'll
be running companies he'll be clear he's
you can tell he's got a good head on his
shoulders yeah he's got like a business
mindset and he can tell he knows the
kind of things that he wants and kind of
things he doesn't want of course and the
kind of things he wants to do and kind
of things he doesn't want to do um and i
think that's very cool man so yeah
random poet appreciation day we
appreciate your poetry cheers poet thank
you um thank you what's up guys it is
that time again to
shed a little bit of love on our boys
over at manscaped
so manscape just wanna send a happy new
years from everyone over there
the ball has officially dropped but that
does not mean that you have to drop the
ball
you guessed it on your balls
it's time you bring sexy back in 2022
let's go and we step up your game with
the manscape performance package 4.0 you
already know the levels you already know
drill
you're gonna join in with the four
million men worldwide who trust manscape
to help
them ring in the new year with the right
tools for the job
you already know where you need to go
but let me remind you one more time
you're going to head over to
manscape.com you're going to pat pap
sierra november gold gonna punch in that
code sng and that's going to allow you
to access exclusively 20 off free
shipping worldwide
manskit.com code is sng
20 off free shipping worldwide it's a
new year it's a new you
and a new you mean snow pubes
[Music]
you heard it here first without any
further ado guys back to the episode
thank you very much let's go okay
yes and stuff like even though we have
no direct influence from poet for
example
a show like this wouldn't be
possible
not necessarily one i know i know what
you mean don't get me wrong i know
exactly what you wouldn't have the
marketplace i know exactly what you mean
because like if you go on youtube so
basically when you you're on youtube if
you're if you're a youtube creator
youtube will give you certain details
about your audience and one of the
details is the other types of channels
your audience likes to watch i've seen
that
so many of those channels are literally
birthplaces of what poet would is the
type of stuff that he's like people like
him him and people like him set the path
for
they're all channels like that
they're all channels like that and even
though like i said i have no direct
relationship with him i've never met him
yeah i don't haven't before i've only i
know of him and i have followed his
stuff but not for years and years yeah
just only for the last couple years yeah
he's the one that he does half card past
class is it he does
yeah yeah a couple other boys um
he obviously does boiler room stuff yeah
he does the other one that he's got what
is bearing them around
yes yes they talk about football and
stuff yeah
i can't remember what that's called um
he used to have another football one
i'm sure
um
he had another podcast where it's just
him and his other boy
in someone's living room um yeah which i
saw chunks of philly go on there one
time i've seen
and he's got like drinks on the table
yeah i've seen that one i'm not no i've
not seen that one i've seen the one he's
done with harry potter yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah that's stuff he's doing in the last
couple years yeah yeah yeah yeah so
[ __ ] hellman has half an hour of
appreciation flowers man hopefully it
gets to him hopefully he does hopefully
the chip one gets him as well yeah i'm
gonna show you everything one gets the
chip definitely won't but hopefully it
does bro because you deserve it yeah and
observe all your flowers mom yeah cool
i'm gonna take a sharp left turn
i'm going to take this conversation a
sharp left turn fast hit me hit me so
for context yeah do you remember
ages ago i can't even remember the
conversation properly that we were
having but we were talking about just
like
the male g spot
and if our kinks were kinking
then we would
have the opportunity to discover if it's
all it's all cracked up to be okay
and like pegging and stinks
one random don
messaged me personally i don't know why
i didn't message the the group the group
he decided to message me yeah yeah i
don't know what that says yeah let me
hear what he comes on camera when pink
shirt thinks he should get messages
about g-spots i don't know but anyway
yeah it might be a light-skinned thing i
don't know maybe it's just my aura i'm
not sure but whatever he has to say
because
he sent me um
a random thing
basically about the uh about his
experience i think i i think we we sent
out a request okay to say
if if guys if you're gay guy or if
you're not or whatever if you've ever
had g-spot experience
hit us up hit us up let us know okay so
he said it's from episode 74 wow and
this is what one this is 140 something
oh yeah bro
so
man said i've got an answer uh to the
g-spot question in episode 74.
i slept with a guy once
i've always slept with girls but this
one time i had a little too much cheap
wine and accidentally slept with a lad
oops
accidentally let's unpack that
brother
you're a gay man you didn't accidentally
sleep with no one yeah you're gay or
brother gay man
that's and that wasn't it literally
okay just and the fact that you said
i've had a little bit too much cheap
wine
yeah that's starting the game i would
say i had too much cheap wine oops
the oops done it for fun we knew you
were gay before we got to where it was
we needed to go man said a little bit
too much cheap wine
my dog
yes sir
we love it um
he said now the male g-spot
wild man
wild
does this remember how he typed it let
me start again
had a little bit too much okay let me
embody this one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right so i'm this guy yeah
and
action
guys i've got an answer to the g-spot
question in episode 74.
i slept with a guy once i've always
slept with girls but this one time had a
little bit too much cheap wine
and accidentally slept with a lad
oops
um
now
the male g-spot
wild man
wild
i nutted and evolved
evolved evolved like a pokemon wow
i knotted and evolved
i've never felt stronger
and manlier
after that i can't explain it
felt like i could fight anyone
what is going on bro
you would have thought man took a
pre-workout outside ma'am you would've
thought you'd have thought you'd smoke
crack
do you remember in wolverwall street
where they smoked crack under the stairs
yes and he's like let's run
let's run like lions and tigers
[Laughter]
that's how he felt wow getting banged
the man said he evolved he yeah knighted
and evolved i've never felt stronger and
manlier
wow the fact that you could props
we're giving flowers yeah of course
that you can say with chess you've never
felt manlier than when a grown-ass man
pounded you
props props props props my g i love that
confidence i said i can't explain it
felt like i could fight anyone i haven't
done it since
but man i'm just saying
maybe maybe a finger or a prostate
massager might be something you should
try once man i said i got you i don't
know what that last difference
again a brother comes on with a pink
t-shirt a little salmon i'm trying to
expand my portfolio
and man said i got you i got you
i don't need to be got
i don't need to be gone get it get it
good thank you
i'm intrigued that's
the whole thing sounds intriguing
but like you said you got to give them
these flowers for the the confidence and
the brevard of saying oh brother felt
more of a man never felt more of a man
after getting backshot i didn't not had
any vibe cheeks were clapped and i felt
like i could fight anyone wow
fair [ __ ] play fair play indeed
brother [ __ ] play like i said my
kinks aren't king kimberly kings
yeah the thing is
i want i would love to be able to
explore i would love but i know myself
you know
i know myself the same way that you're
intolerant to seafood i'm sure you'd
love some lobster tail but it's just not
on the cards it's not
it's not in the cards forever i can't do
it some when i see man slurping oysters
and they're like [ __ ] that's nice i want
a gag
but i wish i liked oysters yeah i know
what you mean i know certain things that
your mind just won't say yes to you just
can't
and there's no way
i'm gonna have two swigs of cheap wine
and arch my back
it's impossible it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen and like i said i
wish my kings were kinking but they're
just not and that's something
is it gonna come with time in my life
i'm gonna have to accept that
and i think i'm nearly there yeah i
think i'm just gonna have to accept the
fact that my king's ain't kinking and
i'm just gonna have to hear
anecdotally yeah that
once uh once your prostate gets the the
dink
you evolve
my kinks are caps bro my kinks are
capped i think there's that's the thing
like there's gateway
drugs and i don't know what my gateway
jug will be
but like
there's a hop skip and a jump between me
getting a girl to eat my body
and getting
i don't know about them not stop him bro
i promise you i promise you
you've lost me after a pump and a half
you've lost me after the first thrust
the first thrust that shudder because
you know oh my god this is the one i'd
lose it you know when you're threading
it yeah so if she was threading me if
it's a pagan tint yeah yeah yeah and she
was threading me yeah and i'm i'm i'm
bracing
waiting for it to get easier yeah yeah
yeah soon she's finished threading
and then
she them
yeah get off me get out of me get off me
i'm done
i'm done here all right
what position would you want to be in
for this thrusting
i wouldn't want another i don't want to
be in any
there's no wanting but
ideal position
ideal position
because there's either doggy arch back
there's flat on your stomach and spread
out cheek
there's flat on your back and then leg
up
and then
i don't know what else they could be
[ __ ] sake those are the three
what are you picking
fam
i'm i'm i'm trying to picture it there's
no way i'm doing like a fetal position
thing
deciding
i'm not doing that i'm not doing that
i'm not archery on my back
i'm not going on all fours
i'm not um laying flat on my stomach
that's for damn sure
that's for damn sure
so what i think i might have to do
is
to explain it
i think you listen listen hear me out
hear me out brother
i might have to do a flat back thing but
listen to me hear me out hear me out
i'm gonna have to
your boy might have to think he's doing
jiu jitsu or something okay i'm gonna
have to get her in a guillotine headlock
in it i'm gonna have to do saturn to the
mask to what's going on
because i can't have my legs my knees up
here i can't i just can't
i promise you i'm not doing that
i promise you would you do that i'd have
to go flat back flat stomach
i'd have to i can't see it coming
i can't see it coming the thing is
i would appreciate flat stomach
but you got to think about this two ways
with flat stomach the reason i said hell
no with flat stomach is because
in my head i want it to feel like a
massage thing
like that's the only way i can imagine
being flat on my stomach with a female
behind me
but
there's only way two ways that stomach
can go
either if i want mine because
i don't want my legs spread open you
don't know you do so don't okay
yeah i don't want my legs spread open
because as soon as they're open yeah i'm
screaming but they're going to be open
like this though when you're on your
back no but if you're on your back see
when i get a girl flat on her stomach
yeah i like legs clothes yeah say i like
cheeks parked yeah and then we're going
in so but in order for me to do that
i need my chest is on her back yeah yeah
are my head's next to her yeah yeah yeah
you're just you're in golf yeah so if
she does that to me
and she's whispering [ __ ] in my ear
you're getting an elbow i i i just can't
feel that helpless i mean
[Laughter]
because i'm seeing it now as i've done
it to girls yeah yeah they're helpless
for her to grab the back of my head and
shove it into the pillow helplessness no
i can't feel that helpless it just
it's a huge turn off yeah feeling that
helpless is a huge turn-off yeah so
as soon as you spread my legs hopeless
as soon as she lays across my back grips
the back of my neck
get off me get the [ __ ] off me yeah so i
just don't know how it's ever gonna
pattern that's what i'm saying my king's
ain't king kingji i just can't pick a
position that's why i guess i'm gonna
have to look her in the boat like a man
no
i promise you now i'm not looking at her
[ __ ] me
i'm not looking out and bang the [ __ ]
literally bang the shower on me i'm not
looking at that that card i literally
can't brother i'd have to go flat on my
stomach do what you wanted me go i'll go
flat on my stomach i'll firm it i'd bite
the pillow close my eyes a [ __ ]
ferment oh deary me
all right fair play that's the only way
i can see it happening that's gonna have
to be where it is
speaking of this is a perfect transition
into
i have to tell you i it to myself again
you i keep picking myself bro hit me to
to be known as the guys
the egg guys
it's astounding how often i ick myself
know what you mean
because you think about it in hindsight
yeah that's all i can think about yeah
it's all i can think about because all i
am inundated with messages from girls
yeah about everything that turns them
off about a guy and it's like i can't
help it now
because a guy can't leave his yard
without giving someone the egg yeah
so the other day
i was in tesco doing a big shop
now
your boy was on the hunt for some
uh coconut milk okay
so i get to the section with coconut
milk yeah world foods well through
something there yeah and they've only
got
coconut milk light
okay and your boy wants the full fat
yeah i want the rich and creamy yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i want it the way
god intended yeah
so i'm i'm looking for this coconut milk
and i can see they've only got this one
to the left on its side
there's a straggling can of organic okay
so full facting okay and i'm like [ __ ]
and it's the bottom shelf okay so i'm
like [ __ ] and i'm i'm like squatting
down
looking at it
[ __ ] sake there's only one can i need
like five because i'm doing a big shot
i look down a little bit
and there there's like a four pack at
the back
bottom shelf at the back who had i can
see it now
it can help i can see it now bro
i had to get my chest to the floor
face pressed against this and my ass was
six foot in the air
and i'm reaching under the thing bro
i thought yeah i was gonna cancel me
i thought yeah i was gonna cancel me
james i promise you now i'm not getting
i'm calling an attendant yeah i'm asking
them have you got any more milk and if
they say there's none there i was like
have a look first of all i'm never
saying to another grown human being got
milk
now i'm never saying that
but fam is the thing is as well it
wasn't even a case of
[ __ ] i'm gonna have to get my face to
the floor an arch it was more of a i've
already squatted down yeah then i got to
my knees and hands
and then i had to like reach under and
then what i really realized when i
really realized what the position i'm
gonna have to partake
it was already too late yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so fam yeah i i basically
wrapped this hand behind my back arched
my ass up in the air and reached for it
fam
and i could hear heels
going past me i was just like
i'm just going to confirm it walks past
like yuck yeah bro 100 i wouldn't be
surprised if he had just kicked me in my
balls from behind
you're not a man
get the [ __ ] off the floor
but yeah that's it i just ignored myself
and just had to firmidge it's constantly
yeah yeah i hear you
it happens but it is it is what it is
bro it does it does happen and it is
what it is yeah so yeah the
sometimes the real [ __ ] [ __ ] is to just
hold it yeah hold it yeah yeah yeah
i agree it is what is g
but from there guys we've had a couple
weeks off um true we have but we're
going to enter
the disgusting domain of x again right
somehow
they keep bringing in that nunu
and uh
yeah it's tough
it's tough so let's see what we got on
the on the menu for today's
ah
this one is my childhood incarnate bro
okay
when he's too scared to say he's next at
the barbers and let someone else go
first
when you're a teenager bro and you first
rock into barbers and you don't know
who's good and who's [ __ ]
and the barber doesn't see you walk in
and he turns around and says who's next
yeah man and you go to move and next on
just standing up it's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah before you know it
you're waiting three three more turns
now oh yeah you're not leaving it for
another two hours oh that's
annoying bro
brutal bro yeah and the fact that old
girl said that
is that she's been in the barbers with
her man seen that and watch him let next
man take a spot
that's embarrassing
he should be ashamed of himself now in
that regard he should be [ __ ] ashamed
of himself
jesus
[Laughter]
where do they get this specificity bro
specificity
wow
when he tries on trainers and squeezes
the toe to see if he has enough room
[ __ ] off
tell her to [ __ ] off
bro [ __ ] man
what the [ __ ]
that one's too funny to me that's
hilarious that's the same as when you uh
i see another one is like when he tries
on shoes and has to do the walk around
the shop oh you're gonna say darting
around the shop dad just has to do the
walk yeah you know when you're in clocks
when you're you and they try them on and
they do the squeeze and they're like
give us a walk and just like
and you have to do that
check the buoyancy out bro and your
mom's like does it fit how does it feel
is it comfortable
yes man and you're wearing school shoes
with with tracky tracky bars you look at
absolute pleb an absolute pleb get me
out of this shop she's a chucky get me
out this [ __ ] shop it's always in
like it's always in
like
like on dale for example oh it's in the
honda in the artist
for those that don't know what they are
it's like a it's like a mall it's an
indoor mall but it's like a shitty
version yeah
trash and it's always like not even
clark's what's the um
daichiman
you know dietrich the greeting dietrich
is like a
dead-end shoe shop
that's where you get this
shoe zone
then mandate that's where they're
telling you to do the walk of shame in
the school show what a waste man's
telling me to do a walk of shame
take me to jd now get me out of this
[ __ ] hellhouse my mom will never take
me to jd it's embarrassing take me to jj
bees when i need new kicks jj b tk max
oh oh i've never been t k max oh ck
baxter's shambles
tk max is a shambles of a store
they don't know what they are well i
used to have a brethren who would shop
in tk maxx and come up with the fire
[ __ ]
every week he'd have some new like back
when ed hardy was a thing ed hard back
when ed hardy
he would rock up with that fresh ed
hardy and you're like oh where'd you get
that and he'd be like oh don't tell no i
got in tk maxx and i'm like you didn't
get that tvx spring well trust me if you
look hard enough you'll find i'll find
your things in tk maxx next thing bro
i'm in there tk max
going through all the items yeah yeah
yeah bad [ __ ] just walking by seeing
me scuffling through the things oh
like some poor person
like a [ __ ]
trying to find a free bounty ramp bro oh
effects on the left i kid about you got
effects in there
[ __ ] ed hardy
ed hold a throwback ah
bro so embarrassing
[Laughter]
i said take me jd bro if you ain't going
jd or footlocker on these shopping trips
with your mum you're pathetic
you're you are partying you are
that's it everyone's gonna laugh at you
because that's the communion mall that's
it's close to the school and it's close
to everywhere close to all the yards so
everyone's there bro
everyone's there your mum picks you up
all right we're going shopping deichman
while all your boys in the galley are in
jjb and jd doing up cinema upstairs
doing up nando's upstairs and you're in
depth
and you're in touch you're indicted
you're fighting me right
[ __ ] fight me bro
nah
find me bowl your enticement on the
tuesday
i'll [ __ ] scrap everyone that's so
embarrassing
being a kid is hard it's tough you've
got no authority
it's tough you've got no say in anything
your mom don't give a [ __ ] about your
feelings man your feelings all your
friends my boys are doing nando's and
i'm enticement that's so relevant for
you no i did i have no idea how relevant
that is bro
oh it's funny bro [ __ ] man
[ __ ]
speaking of i remember there was one
time most embarrassing moment of my life
today yeah
yeah embarrassing i remember
i was
15 16 yeah and my boy had just got a job
in foot locker
and at the time obviously i live in
northampton our closest footballer comes
in milton keynes he got a job in foot
locker in milton keynes
and he lived in north and he lived in
north of me okay so one saturday where
he went working
he got all the mans together all the
galley together and said he's got our
friends and family discounting let's go
foot locker
let's splash the discount at the time
fam no word of a lie was like seventy
percent a raw it was lavish bro i had a
young 50 spot yeah that's all i had i
had one pinky bro yeah i from my
birthday yeah one pinky yeah didn't have
a job didn't have no money i'd never
used to get ema nothing i had one pink
note so yeah
i had 150 spots what i had to my name
bro 50 quid so i'm thinking i'mma be
able to run up in there and get
some buff trainers for like 20 quid
[Music]
and still have
something for lunch or whatever these
cookies are fine
benny when you were you bro they're
expending you uh-huh
yeah millie's cookies were [ __ ] teeth
so i thought we're gonna run up in
milton keynes yeah i'm gonna splurge on
some 20-pound trainers that should be
like 100.
um i'm still gonna have
time for millie's cookies and sushi
and everything's going to be gagged yeah
then we rock up in there
my man takes us all in there and what
i'm saying there's hoes with us bro
i'm 16 brother
i'm not used to this yeah
it's ting's about yeah and i'm thinking
i'm gonna get lavish trainers it's gonna
be barf i can't wait bro rock up in
there
so
soon as we get in there
my boy's manager comes up
and he's like
jason no does it this is what he said
as soon as we walk in the door
he looks at my boy it says jason no
i remember i was like what he's like
you're not doing this again
my heart's racing at this point you're
not doing this again and he's are you
talking about what are you talking about
and then he's like oh you can't just
keep bringing everyone in for their
friends and family taking their did it
doesn't work like that you've got all
these people i know what you're trying
to do he's like he's not even like
that's not even a bright light he looks
at me and said this is my brother i'm
not getting everyone nothing this is my
brother he's coming for some trainers
his family like et cetera et cetera
and then he was like oh whatever man
so he walks off and then he goes to my
boy goes to me pick your kicks
tell the lady to bring his eyes all the
ting um
and then i'm gonna i'm gonna sort out
and then when you're ready
so i pick kicks
they're like 80 bar carmen bought kicks
they were i pick kicks
um
i'm getting angry telling this story
i pick up the kicks yeah
um
pick up the kicks
homeboy gets my size
my boy's still chatting to the manager
mm-hmm
when i told him no jason yeah yeah my
boy still chatting to the manager yeah
and he's looking at me like here's kind
of comfortable so i picked my size get
the tings and then um
the
brother who bought the guy who brings me
to shoes
they don't really do this anymore i
don't think
but they used to let you wear them out
the store
did they so what obviously the box has
the ting on it
that they scan and you pay
but if i wanted i could put the shoes on
put my shoes in the box they'll scan the
thing and i'll pay for it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah i said to my man he
tried i tried them on
um tried them both on they fit they look
lavish with the gums i'm wearing hoes
are smiling everything's blessed yeah
yeah my boys are spurred in yeah yeah
yeah
um so i put my kicks in the box
take my box up to the front
um
as i get there
my boy turns around he's like
yeah it's not going to pattern
i said what
i said the discount's not it's not gonna
that's not good he's not having it
donnie's not having it and he's kicking
up a foster you know if i hate his job
anymore i'm gonna quit and i'm like
say say less
he's like yeah yeah but you're just
gonna have to pay full price
i've only got fifty damn i've only got
50.
big man thing
i had to go to the bench take off the
shoes
take my crusty muddy shoes out put them
back on put the thing and then
sell all right sorry for wasting your
time
i wanted to put a stone cold bullet in
my head
and that said there was hoes about if
i'm putting the shoes over spud in the
neck
i should bottle you
i've never felt so exposed
i've never felt so violated
i felt naked and afraid bro
i wanted to fight everyone and just
scream and cry
i was like why is my life like this man
that's too funny why is my life
funny and i think that's i think stuff
like that is the birthplace of it okay i
think stuff like that is the birthplace
of ick where there's hoes about a man
has to return trains that you can't
afford ah man
and yes i just like i know you're not a
man i know you're still a kid yeah but
you're really not a man yeah because you
didn't even you were banking on this
discount
you didn't have a sec plan b yeah you
didn't have a plan b there literally was
no plan b you didn't have you needed the
discount bro
you're a joke
you're a joke
i just want you to know that oh
good job
it's so unfair
fam is someone fair and the thing that
pisses me off as well is that
not again with this
[Music]
the thing the thing that pisses me off
as well
is that homeboy who worked there
he he was from like a well-off family
okay so his mom and his nan and his
stuff would always give him money when
we were kids so he always had money bro
talking like two 300 pound in cash just
always it's like walking around money
he could have bought ten of them [ __ ]
trainers if you wanted to yeah yeah yeah
so for him
him even like
him even saying like oh [ __ ] this job
anyway [ __ ] and just quitting on the
spot miner and then still going shopping
in the milton keynes
the hose were lapping it up yeah and
your boy was wearing his dusty reeboks
bro
[ __ ] and i allegedly was like why is
life like this
[ __ ] hell that's that's tough as a 16
year old that's tough it was harsh very
tough it was harsh bro
nah man that's not fair
it was tough
man didn't have a plan b whatsoever bro
you're banking on that i was oh i was
begging for it [ __ ] i was begging for it
but he sold me on its side of course of
course of course
and he just ran me down the river to
drown
and then a man said don't worry this is
my brother it's just him
you would escape good for the whole
the thing heist i was the full guy
you were and when [ __ ] hit the fan he
wasn't there to back he wasn't he wasn't
you got to the tail and that said just
to let you know it's not padded right
he's i'm sorry he's not having it's not
evident and then to him he felt betrayed
yeah by the manager so he was like [ __ ]
this yeah yeah and then spent in in
milton keynes
spent in there or bought order hoes
burger king and
i'm just like just literally kill me
then [ __ ] it because if that's what
we're doing then just kill me [ __ ] you
it was it was painful bro sorry brother
right a couple more eggs and we're done
yeah
um
oh this one's relevant to me bro not to
me but i see this all the time okay when
he posts a selfie wearing glasses and
you can see him holding the phone in the
reflection of the glasses
so embarrassing
so embarrassing bruv i hate stuff like
that i hate stuff like that
when he's riding a bike dings his bell
and no one moves
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] that's shameful that's
shameful when you bump down that curve
yeah yeah yeah into oncoming traffic i
[ __ ] hate it or if like if you're
you're hiring people um you get that
no one moves so you literally have to
get off the bike yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh terrible yeah screaming excuse
me excuse me on your left you're lefty
though shameful oh this one
when he has his window wipers on full
speed and it's barely raining
thing's just screeching
that's annoying that's annoying man
that's annoying yeah
you're a joke man banging left and right
for no reason
you just don't look like a confident
driver yeah you know what i mean you
just don't look like you know what
you're doing
and you're driving you know
you're in control of this you're in
control of this you're in control of me
nah bro take care of man take care of us
because the way to wipe his wipe in
doesn't make sense
it doesn't make sense [ __ ] it oh that's
funny [ __ ] hell that's funny
i've seen that one before
oh this one's brutal bro
when he starts walking to a tilt and the
cashier walks away so he needs to go to
the back of the queue
i've never seen that happen but the
thought of that i would bang that
cashier in his face come back here what
do you actually mean
that's never um
that specifically hasn't happened when
they've walked off but it's happened to
me what i've gone to a till
and you don't realize that you get that
the shutter thing is closed oh did you
know they got that little thing here
yeah yeah and someone's standing there
having a chin wag
and then you only notice it when they
you know the thing that separates on the
belt
you know they're little separated
they put that at the end yeah and it
says close closed yeah yeah and you're
just rocking up you put your basket on
the thing and this is closed you're just
like
[ __ ] my life from the next things long
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] all of you
you just and you know they're pretending
not to look yeah yeah you know they saw
him yeah just like quick quick gluts
annoy your [ __ ]
the last one is the most painful thing
you can experience as a man
the most painful thing you can
experience on the man
[Laughter]
when he opens the car door but it's too
heavy and it closes again before he can
get out
at least you have to say that fast to
get rid of
bro
the times i've done that and my leg gets
caught another thing
if i open the door get one leg out and
the wind shuts it on me
oh
no i feel like a toddler no i feel like
a [ __ ] nah
that's unfair that's unfair there's
nothing we can do about the wind that's
unfair
and you know it's the same you know
what's even worse than that
you know when
you know when there's bear with you you
know when pre-drinks has been
pre-drinking and new man booked the
seven seat up
and you arrive at your destination and
it's your turn to open the thing the
slider door
yeah
you're fiddling with it i hate that
yeah
and it will not open so donnie has to
kiss his teeth get out and just press
the button and just like it's so
embarrassing i hate it so embarrassing
bro
i've got one here
when it's
when he pushes back the car seat and
then has to pull it back a bit because
he was too ambitious
bro when you flick that lever and
gravity takes over fam
it's embarrassing what can you do all
right
like that
if that happens to me let's say a
chick's driving my dog she's paying as
well i flick it
and i'm all the way back i won't be able
to look at her because
i know for a fact she's seen me see her
she's just looking around and the thing
you have to rent your neck up
and then get it back up oh and that's
embarrassing it's embarrassing
i'll stay there oh it was all
intentional shut up
shut up and drive
no rihanna
[ __ ] hell
oh which other ones are there
when you go to his room and he has one
flat pillow on the bed
just the one flat pillow
thing is
that's me
i prefer one pillow
but i understand it makes you look like
you live in a hostel
you don't know what comfort is it
a man said he prefers one pillow a flat
one like that femme
a young one pillow it's underrated for
your neck
it feels good
two pillows my thing's like this no not
for me your phone i know not for you not
for me i need the double nah i drapes
one off that goes in between my legs
like a punk and then i sleep on one i'm
kipping i can't sleep on one pillow my
neck is too lodged it's too lodged i
need support that can't i can't lay flat
and have my head like this
i need support brother nah bro nah it's
not that's not for me it's each day
wrong
when he's late and has to run with his
backpack on and he's holding the straps
like this um year seven year eight that
was me bro
i think there's one you read as well
similar to that got a backpack on in
there he has to tie your shoelace and
the back thing goes there
scrap me you have to fight me you have
to fight me
you have to fight me
because it's embarrassing oh it's brutal
fam it's embarrassing oh there's nothing
there's actually nothing worse than
seeing a backpack going like this when
you're pam there's nothing worse there
is nothing worse you can hear danny
donny's apple cause bouncing in the
lunchbox you [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
you
[ __ ]
man came with the hard bees as well you
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's too funny
bro that's too funny school x are valid
oh bro it's just it's just valid it's
unfair
it's unfair man
anyway i think that's that's all that's
[ __ ] sake yeah that's what we're gonna
have to call it day there guys thank you
so much thank you for today mom happy
monday um
we love you as always and then um we're
gonna we're gonna catch you on thursday
if you're if you're really what's up
we'll catch you on thursday
if
you're a [ __ ] as well we'll see you
next week
[ __ ] i wasn't expecting to say that
them hard bees they sweep me bro those
jokes all right guys
love love
[Music]